I saw this tweet earlier people were
saying that Yemen basically declared war
on Israel well it's the houthi militia
that has claiming they've launched
attacks on Israel they're Irani uh
Iranian backed and so there is concern
that the war is beginning to escalate
however calm down there my friends
because it seems like the Ukraine war is
over and so while all war is bad it is
like it's kind of good news that
zalinski is losing Time Magazine has
published their front page story
zilinski is desperate to win but his
advisor saying they've lost the war
Russia is winning they're losing the War
I should say to to be clear and there's
little interest in the US to continue
funding what is already lost as we we
said this some time ago it looks like
Russia's won this one in the meantime
however it looks like things are
escalating over Israel we've got other
breaking news that Israel has now taken
uh has admitted too bombing a refugee
camp killing at least 50 civilians and
uh apparently the went on CNN they said
they did it so things are getting
absolutely horrifying right now and as
this escalates there's concern with
other nations saying that if Israel
keeps keeps up these bombing campaigns
which kill civilians then it's going to
escalate further hopefully as we see
Ukraine wind down the things that are
escalating in the in in the Middle East
do not become a World War III scenario
or go beyond the region we're all hoping
for that we'll talk about that before we
get started over to cast brew.com for
the best cup of coffee you've ever had
go to cast brew and buy our limited
edition it's Halloween ladies and
gentlemen it is it is Halloween and if
you have not picked up our rerise with
Roberto Jr special zombie blend you're
missing out we are mocking our own dead
mascot Roberto Jr and it's kind of sad
but you know we love him so we we gave
him not only does he have rise with
Roberto Jr rest in peace he has a zombie
Edition which is a a different blend and
then we have appalachin kns that's my
favorite rise with the brto junior as
everyone else favorite but uh buy your
Casper coffee it supports the show and
I'll tell you this right now we're
building a coffee shop it is taking a
million years to get done permitting and
government re remodeling we've got to
like now we've got to you know like fix
supports and stuff but it is happening
and I will tell you this these locations
that we're looking to build for physical
Hangouts we are able to do it because
you buy Cas brew coffee so when we're
looking at buying new materials and
doing the construction that money is
coming from the sales of CAS Brew so if
you want to support that mission go to
casw but also go to to
timcast.net
andal hi there Tim how you doing how you
uh good thanks for thanks for coming
glad to be here thanks for having me who
are you what do you do I'm the former
NYU Professor who took on the woke mob
for free speech I am a former Marxist
turn radical libertarian wow and I am
the author of uh 12 books uh including
Springtime for snowflakes thought
criminal and the great reset and the
struggle for Liberty and speaking of
Liberty I'm running for president as a
Libertarian well all right well thanks
for hanging out this should be very
interesting okay we got Brett hanging
out what is going on guys yes I am Brett
dvic the host of Pop Culture crisis and
speaking of Roberto Jr we have a brand
new crisis party sound effect see every
time we get a certain amount of super
chats new crisis party sound goes off
and now we have a remix with Roberto Jr
only it's done by Ian screaming really
really loudly doing his Roberto Jr
impression him and Phil together so it's
good hello everybody I am uh Phil abanti
lead singer of all the remains very
failed musician anti-communist and
counterrevolutionary and I'm here with
my man surge.com indeed uh I'm ready
when you are Tim let's get ready here's
a story from the New York Times Yemen's
sui militia claims to have launched an
uh launched an attack on Israel the
Israeli military said it had thwarted a
batch of aerial threats but did not say
who was behind them Yemen sui militia
claimed an attempted attack on Southern
Israel in uh on Tuesday saying it had
launched a large batch of ballistic and
cruise missiles as well as drones toward
Israeli targets the iran-backed militia
carried out the attempted assault in
response to what it called brutal
Israeli American aggression in Gaza the
military spokesman spokes smokesman Yaya
serea said on the social media platform
acts Mr said the attack was the third
operation conducted by the houthis in
support of our persecuted Brothers in
Palestine and threatened further missile
and drone assaults the times could not
independently verify the claims on
Tuesday the isra Israeli military said
its aerial defense system had
intercepted a surfac to- surface missile
fired towards Israel from the area of
the Red Sea it said it has also
intercepted other aerial threats in the
area none of which entered Israeli
territory now now here's here's the big
concern I suppose if you're looking at
this through the lens of uh the Ben
chapiro perspective his view is that if
the US does not get involved and Stamp
Out aggression toward or assist in the
stamping out of aggression towards
Israel we are going to see an escalation
of these kinds of assaults which results
in Israel taking the nuclear option
perhaps quite literally resulting in a
world War II scenario when uh basically
the idea is there's two ideas one in
response to a serious military threat
that that could end Israel Israel says
fire everything we've got the second
scenario similar is Israel facing its
demise says we're going to fire
everything everywhere and we're going to
force the intervention of other
countries to stop this conflict yeah and
it's the exact inverse of what Shapiro
is saying the more we do the more we
intervene the more the greater the
threat of this turning into a wider uh
conflict more countries that'll get draw
in you know you have uh of course
everything points back to Iran here
supposedly with Hezbollah and now the
houthis and so we're looking at the
possibility of drawing other uh actors
into this and the United States is
seemingly itching to attack Iran and
that's that's a problem so you know the
arming and funding of Israel is
outrageous this is drawing all these
actors out so we're actually our
interventions are causing this uh this
conflict to
escalate so the the I guess my question
is if the US does nothing do you think
these other countries these Iranian
backed militias in Iran do you think
they just ignore Israel or do you think
they attack Israel I mean if the US does
nothing but fund them to the tune of
$3.8 billion a year and now another 14
billion uh then of course there's going
to be our involvement we're already
implicated in the whole in the whole
conflict because of the uh arms and
funding we've been giving them over all
this time so yeah we need to re retrench
we need to pull back all of our funding
and yeah we would see that if we didn't
intervene in all these conflicts there
would be less conflict in the world and
especially the Middle East do you think
that if the United States were not
giving uh funding giving weapons and
essentially essentially it's probably
just giving weapons that the US pays uh
weapons manufacturers for but if the US
were not and the Israelis were just
buying weapons from us manufacturers do
you think that the the houthis and Iran
would look at it any differently because
in my opinion I don't think that the
people the countries and and states that
don't like Israel would see a
distinction even if we weren't giving it
away if we were like look us firms are
allowed to sell you like Ron and Boeing
can sell you weapons but we're not
paying for it I don't really strongly
believe that the the Iranians are going
to consider that a they'll call it a
difference without a distinction well I
don't know we we we're giving them the
money and then they buy the arms that's
how it works 3.8 billion a year so I
think that you know if if I don't think
first of all Israel would be able to
afford as much arms if it weren't for
these outlandish uh grants every year
and uh then add 14 billion on top of it
and you've got the United States totally
implicated so I mean I don't see how uh
that helps anything at all and so yeah
if they were just buying their arms and
and largely from the United States
perhaps those countries would still
consider the us implicated but there's
no doubt that our you know that we're
fully involved in this because of that
and right now us rockets and bombs are
falling on children in Palestine this is
an outrage and this is should be
something that we completely oppose uh
it has no we have no business doing this
and it's I think it's blood on our hands
frankly I agree the US shouldn't fund it
but I I just am not I'm not convinced
that other countries would see a
distinction I let's try it for once we
haven't we haven't tried this ever you
know so why why don't we give it a try
100% 100% I'm I'm not I'm not trying to
push back against the idea actually I
think we tried it during the uh the
barber
Wars the US the US was kind of like hey
can we not go to war with you guys like
what's going on and then they were like
n we're going to keep stealing bring
there was no Israel back then but yeah
no but my point is like it was only the
founding fathers who were like the
United States will not be involved in
these foreign conflicts and then you get
to you know late 1800s early 1900s and
the politicians then are like I think
the US should be involved in foreign
affairs and just start setting up
military conquests why not and there you
have it and now we have 800 bases around
the world oh yeah yeah yeah and one in
Israel by the way apparently there's a
secret base in Israel right now it's
called 152 it's this very uh you know
nondescript name and that we're actually
we have forces located in there they're
saying it's just uh living
accommodations but it it has uh US
forces in it uh this has been revealed
so site 512 is that yes that's it yeah
so we have this is this is The Intercept
right us quietly expands secret military
base in Israel government documents
pointed construction at a classified US
base offer rare hints about little noted
US military presence near Gaza and there
was there was some reporting hard to
know what's true claiming that US forces
were actually in Gaza during The
Invasion and may be there now and uh
perhaps it's very hard to tell I mean
all this is kept secret these 2,000
troops that were sent over they're
they're sent to an undisclosed location
we don't know where they are the defense
department will not say where they are
so I mean for for certain military
reasons that makes sense but we we still
don't know they may be in Israel what
what TR I'm not familiar with the with
the The Troop deployment I know that
there's two Marine Expeditionary units
that are with to the carrier groups but
I don't know about yeah there's uh 2,000
troops that been sent over 2,000 in you
know I don't know if they're in infantry
or Marines or what whatever they are
they're there and in the region but they
won't tell us where they are in the
region I bet they're in Iraq and then of
course we have two aircraft carriers in
the uh in the Mediterranean and uh you
know we have uh tons of arms just loaded
around so I think they're trying to bait
the us into a conflict if something get
struck we're going to go in oh yeah well
now with the US hostages you have you
have the argument that oh the reason we
have Delta Forces on the ground yeah is
because of the hostages the the presence
of 200 US troops in Iraq and another 900
in eastern Syria both on missions
against the Islamic State this
is uh I'm not looking Trump tried
bringing them back yeah but don't you
think that um or what what are your
thoughts on this I mean a lot of people
say that uh if the US is not if the US
just retracts everything China just
sweeps in I don't agree I mean they they
moved into uh Afghanistan well they're I
mean you know the thing is we're in
terms of China what we're doing is
provoking them as well because we're
talking about now sending uh military
aid to Taiwan this is an utter
provocation so we're drawing China into
conflict seemingly on purpose and I
don't think China is going to try to uh
take F of all they don't have the
military power to do it they do not have
the military power to take over the
United States or inade us or anything
like that no but I mean they'll start
they'll they'll grow that power they'll
move into Central America there's
already concerns they they're going to
try and make a move they were trying to
build the Nicaraguan Canal to gain
control or or at least compete with the
Panama Canal people were uh there's a
rumor about their them trying to gain
control of the Panama Canal they'll uh
they're going to they're already moving
into Africa and South America yeah me
this these are not military conquest
though and no it's more like you know
the West uses the IMF it's the belon
road initiative and this is how they're
growing their soft power and you know
frankly we should open up trade with
China we we are now embargoing their uh
chips we refuse to send certain chips to
China what's this going to do this is
already hurting our economy and what
it'll do for them is they'll just go
elsewhere for these chips uh they'll
make them themselves or get get them
elsewhere we are not sending them chips
is what you're saying we refuse to send
them certain chips yeah there's a
there's a concern though that they're
reverse engineering a lot of our
intellectual property a of our
technology but they're also sending us
compromised electronics that was a big
story a few years ago where they're like
your toaster could be broadcasting a
signal and you wouldn't know and it's
stealing your information I I don't
think China is our real our real uh
threat the number one primary enemy
frankly who is the state our government
our government our government well
elaborate why I mean our government has
look who has who's responsible for more
deaths of Americans than our government
uh we have sent more people over to die
than any country has killed so we're
actually Prov provoking other countries
we're entering in all these military
Expeditions and in that way the state
itself is more responsible for us deaths
than China Iran uh Russia uh or uh North
Korea combined you know I thought about
this and I was thinking that it it seems
like there's an occupying Force that's
been controlling this country because
the American people don't want war right
they never want war Almost Never and yet
here we are consistently going into Wars
without having declared war on anybody
and then I think no it's probably better
to just say we were sold out by our
politicians who continue to sell us out
so it's not so much that we're occupied
it's that uh we have a fractured uh uh
government and a and and corrupt
politicians everyone agrees with well I
don't know how fractured it is because
when it comes to war and Military uh
Expeditions and and foreign policy this
is a unip party they're not even there's
no distance between these people it does
seem to be like the only time they ever
actually agree on anything is when it's
going to war in other countries have
there been polls done recently about
what the American public's thoughts are
on war right now given obviously we know
what the American people think of war in
Ukraine but have there been studies or
any type of polls that have been done
talking about what they think about
military intervention in Israel
interestingly there was a pull down on
Biden's approvability rating which fell
by 11% uh among Democrats so that's a
good sign so it went from 86 to 75% and
for uh Arab Americans it fell like uh
from like 58 to 177% in in a matter of
weeks so uh interestingly there is a
divide in the uhu in the population in
terms of support for Biden uh because
you know I mean the Le a lot of the left
doesn't want this uh conflict now they
are hypocrites because they were fully
in support of the Ukraine war and the
right is also hypocritical because now
they're in support of this war Israel
but they weren't in support of the war
in Ukraine so and also in hindsight they
opposed the rocky War isn't that
convenient I want to pull up this story
we got this from The Wall Street Journal
Israeli air strike uh uh hits jabalia
refugee camp and forces extend their
Advance into Gaza Strip we have live
updates apartment buildings were
flattened in the strikes Egypt said it
would defend its its territory but take
in wounded Palestinians so I think we
have a a clip from CNN that I'll play
for you well I don't know if B basically
this is from Ahmad uh uh elen he says
Wolf Blitzer you knew that there were
innocent civilians in the refugee camp
right IDF spokesperson says this is a
tragedy of War let me just play the clip
because I don't want anything being
taken out of context for you guys so
we'll just uh we'll play this clip for
you now but even if that Hamas Commander
was there amidst all those Palestinian
refugees who are in that in that jabala
refugee camp Israel still went ahead and
Dropped a Bomb there attempting to kill
this Hamas uh this Kamas amas Commander
knowing that a lot of innocent civilians
men women and children presumably would
be killed is that what I'm
hearing that's not what you're hearing
wol we again were focused on this
Commander again who you'll get more data
who this man was killed many many
Israelis uh we're doing everything we
can these are it's a very complicated
battle space there could be
infrastructure there there could be
tunnels there we're still looking into
it and we'll give you more data as they
moves
ahead I mean you know that there are a
lot of refugees a lot of innocent
civilians men women and children in that
refugee camp as well
right this is the tragedy of War wolf I
mean we wow as you know we've been
seeing for days move South civilians are
not involved with Hamas please move
South just trying to get a little bit
more information you knew there were
civilians there you knew there were
refugees all sorts of refugees but you
decided to still drop a bomb on that
refugee camp attempting to kill the
samas commander by the way was he
killed I can't confirm yet I mean wolf
should have just let him answer the
question then he just jumped to another
one we get the point Israel says They
Carried an air strike that Hamas claim
killed him more than 50 people in gaza's
jabali refugee camp dozens of bodies
here here's here's my issue with this uh
that that CNN interview yeah damning but
they but Hamas lied about that about the
hospital
and many on the left prop Palestinian
groups and left lied about the hospital
so when stories like this come out what
am I supposed to do I don't know about
the hospital frankly I'm not sure that
the story has really been disb debunked
that well it has they claimed the they
claimed the hospital was leveled and 500
well the hospital wasn't leveled they
hit the parking lot yep and it may have
been a couple dozen injured with with a
certain certain number of deaths we
don't know but there's been other
hospitals hereit and they've told them
to get out out of the other hospitals
they've said evacuate these hospitals
then they tell them they're going to
bomb the north so move South while
they're bombing the South um this is
unbelievable so there's nowhere for
these people to go they're shooting fish
in a barrel and they've got them trapped
there in a in a a virtual concentration
camp I'm sorry if that sounds like
leftist rhetoric but these people are in
a walled area No E no exit no exit what
do we do nothing should the US just back
away should not first of all the UN had
a movement to have a a a ceasefire and
we were one of like seven countries that
refused to go along with it Hillary
Clint Hillary Clinton is very anti-as
fire there was a ceasefire when Hamas
made the initiated the the terrorist
attack like three weeks ago there was a
ceasefire between Gaza and Israel then
Hamas broke the ceasefire that's what
started this whole shind dig that's
going on now it's it's very T you know
listen I'm not going to adjudicate the
whole history of the region but there's
no way October 7th is the beginning of
this yeah that's why that's why I'm kind
of like I got I got I got a really good
idea guys we should not be involved
exactly it's like you're there's a very
serious fight happening between two of
your neighbors and people keep asking
whose side you're on I'm like bro I
don't live there I don't know what's
going on they're like yeah well like you
know your kid like your your your your
dad is giving weapons to one of your
neighbors and you're like maybe we
shouldn't be doing that I don't think
that there's actually any good answer
for the United States at all because I
don't think that we should give any
money I don't think we should be funding
I don't think we should have we should
in any way be involved in it but I also
don't think that if we do what is the
right thing for the United States which
is not fund it not give any money not
support we're still going to be
implicated and we're still going to be
attacked even if we're not dealing with
actual Terror attacks we're still going
to be considered the evil Satan that
supports Israel and whatever just
because of our history yeah I mean it
doesn't help that we bombed Iraq for no
you know for complete under a completely
false pretext killed hundreds of
thousands of people and created millions
of refugees any amount of like back
pedling now where we if we were to just
suddenly start backing away from any
funding of War would make us look like
the ultimate Hypocrites in the enti I
think look Trump trump gets elected to
the to them to to the people on the
other side the the ones that are if
you're talking about the people in Gaza
or Hamas they're going to look at I mean
they're going to look at as as
Hypocrites anyways see I just strongly
feel this is an anti-western movement
the reason so the Palestinians that are
on the ground in you know in Israel or
in Gaza or whatever they hate the
Israelis because they have that Direct
direct actual situation they're fighting
them they're being oppressed by the the
Israelis and and that's the situation
for them the out the the broader context
where you're talking about the region
and other countries sometimes Western
countries the people that are pro
Palestine and against the Israelis
they're more about being against the
West more broadly they're against
Western Society they don't they tend to
not be uh they not they tend to not be
supportive of democ racies they want
more authoritarian types governments so
it's not and I'm not saying that I have
an answer I'm just I'm this if the West
lived up to its proclaimed values
perhaps they wouldn't feel that way I
mean the West has colleges have kind of
implicated that to them and I mean go
further down to Tik Tok and all these
other ways in which kids get this
messaging now like I don't know how much
of that would even matter now I do agree
like I don't think we should be funing
any side of it but I think that what
it's created for me is what I call I'm
in a like it's post concern it's like a
post concern attitude where it's like
there's so much information there's so
much propaganda there's so much coming
out from every side in a part of the
world that I inherently have nothing to
do with other than my government's
continued intrusion in other people's
business what am I what am I as an
American citizen whose taxes are going
to fund all this what am I actually
supposed to do in this situation you're
telling me I have to care about this
side they're telling me I have to care
about this side I'm not allowed to care
about the people here apparently that's
the only people you're not allowed to
care about hold on which people the
Americans people actually
living like okay how about the people I
mentioned last how about the people in
Hawaii how about the people in any of
the things that have gone on here in the
last several years help helping trim
down the debt in this country all of the
things that we have to worry about State
Side before we go and start getting back
reinol in other countries we might we
might revolt against the fact that
they're robbing us to do this I mean
they're robbing the American public the
American taxpayer to to f these words I
think Trump was one of the first
attempts of people saying we will
rationally decide this man will enact
many of these things and uh now things
are getting pretty tense with the
machine's desperate attempts to keep
Trump out of office I mean it's it's
crazy when we have uh Scott Horton of
all people being like Trump tried
getting our troops out and they lied to
us he tells he tells the truth about
these matters and but Trump wasn't some
you know savior I mean he he killed
solomani for for uh you know and could
have that could have instigated some
conflict with Iran imagine if if Iran
had killed one of our major generals I
mean this would have drawn us into war
the only reason they didn't get drawn
into war is because we have a greater
force but that's not the way the United
States should be uh acting ac across the
planet we ought to be the beacon on the
hill in the sense that we are free
people that people admire that trades
with other countries is cooperative and
peaceful this would actually promote
peace worldwide it is true Phil that
what you said about it being an
anti-American movement did you see the
the infographic meme the other day it
says free Palestine is a queer movement
free Palestine is uh okay that's at the
heart of it it's an anti-western
anti-democracy movement more than
anything else it's not that they support
or love Palestine or Gaza it's that they
love the fact that it puts the West
between IR rock in a hard place in
dealing with the conf because there is
and you're right because there is no
good policy that that's going to to make
the United States look good I personally
like I've said over and over we
shouldn't be involved we shouldn't have
troops over there we shouldn't be
spending money on it we shouldn't be
funding it Israel can fight its own War
I like I 100% believe that but that
doesn't mean that if that were the
course of action that the United States
took that the rest of the world would be
like oh cool the United States is doing
the right thing or the good thing there
are still going to be people that are
going to say oh the West is bad
America's bad democracy bad Li
I mean when you when you try to export
democracy with bombs like we did in Iraq
of course people are going to be
skeptical about what is this democracy
you're talking about yeah I I agree and
I just don't think that I don't think
that it that it's I don't think that
it's limited to the Middle East I I
think that that there is an anti-western
anti- liberal movement that is pretty
Global I think there's an anti-liberal
movement in the United States I don't
think I don't think there are any
liberals left we're looking at an
illiberal left effectively but you know
there's there's no liberalism here there
are it's just they're the post liberals
they're the the disaffected Liberals the
the funny part is is like in what I do
like talking about movies celebrities
Hollywood and pop culture you see this
right now because a bunch of celebrities
try to make a post that makes everybody
happy and they can't make anyone happy
and this is the first time they haven't
been given a clear marching order about
who the good guys and who the bad guys
are when they write their virtue
signaling letters uh everyone gets mad
at them from every side and I think that
the people that are inherently
anti-American and anti-western love that
about this yeah you see I think you see
the the the people that
are only T that only understand the wave
tops of the movement the one are those
those are the people that are shocked
when they are kind of learning what
decolonization means and that it's a
violent revolution that's being endorsed
and and they're shocked they're like
wait a minute I didn't I don't want to
see people getting their heads cut off I
don't want to see you know people's
businesses and lives being destroyed
well that's what decolonization is we
could jump back to the China thing okay
what are we what are we doing with
reference to China That's weakening us
well we're we're doing all kinds of
things we're instituting a de
de-industrialization campaign in the
west uh with the ESG and the stakeholder
capitalism which is about eroding our
industrial base uh supposedly to uh
mitigate so-called climate change and G
uh greenhouse gas emissions and this is
you know this is favoring China that's
something that we're doing to ourselves
it's a self-inflicted wound it's a you
know suicidal in effect we're taking our
Industries and we're saying you can't
burn fossil fuels and we must use this
ESG to force all these companies into
these uh into this regime while China
then gains all this power and and wealth
on the on the back end because they're
not doing it so let let me pull up this
story this is from The Wall Street
Journal as well it's actually just below
the other one Israel goes unnamed on
China online map so a lot of people
noticed that two big companies you've
got alib Ababa and I believe Bou have
removed Israel from their maps that is
to say this is the CCP I I there there's
no private sector in China that just at
the same time decides hey we're doing
this thing it looks like the Chinese
Communist party has said there is no
Israel now but what so the concern here
there's been a bunch of reporting or I
should say opinions and Analysis
suggesting this shows China is gearing
up to join this on the side of
Palestine it's possible I mean they're
saying Israel doesn't exist on their map
and I mean this is yeah listen I China
is a totalitarian state and they
Institute uh their measures without any
kind of consent uh there's no question
about it so I would I'm not surprised
that they would do this I don't
necessarily means that uh think it means
that they're going to intervene right
now Al but it's a it's a it's a definite
uh I mean look at bricks right right
China is absolutely in in partnership
with Iran and this is this is the fear
World War II is NATO versus bricks yeah
it doesn't have to be World War II you
know look uh bricks could be actually
something that's good in the sense that
if we opened up our own trade then we
could probably be part of this and we
don't have to disband our our
affiliations and our uh our our trade
associations as we're doing right now
the the the conflicts that we're
creating and being you know and really
escalating uh are actually caus in these
Rifts okay because like when we sent
arms to Ukraine and I think even though
you know you said the Ukraine war is
dying down I bet you that 64 billion is
still going over there so being stolen
by somebody yeah going to find its way
into the pockets of Biden perhaps yeah
again I should say yeah I agree I mean
there's no question there's corruption
here
yeah well hopefully it doesn't become
World War II I suppose I hope not but
this is this what we we're seeing now
from China
is like the first red flag where I think
we should be concerned like guys we need
this to turn down and so I'm I'm I'm now
especially with this uh bombing of the
refugee camp I I see a lot of people I
see Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton had
a statement recently where she was like
ceasefire you know Israel is being
attacked and you want a ceasefire but
Hamas is not going to give it and you
know anytime Hillary Clinton says
something I'm like the opposite must be
true yeah absolutely so she comes out
and she's like we can't see fire and I'm
like maybe we need a ceasefire and so uh
we need barometers like that out there
right exactly you know it's like uh uh I
was I was hanging out in a poker room we
were talking about um Jim Kramer and uh
cuz because I I can't remember what came
up something about it's going to snow
the farmers Farmers Almanac and then uh
someone mentioned tracking stocks and I
was like oh yeah if you if you if you
short short anything kmer says you're
going to be up and this one guy go
actually yeah I think it's up the the
it's up 14% if if you bought if you
shorted everything he told you to buy
you're up 14% so far for the year
tremendous tremendous but anyway my
point is Hillary Clinton says no we
can't do it we need war and I'm kind of
like all right let's figure out this
peace solution and I think I think it's
fair to say that like I I agree Hamas
attacked Israel killed civilians and
there's there's two ways to look at this
one way is Israel is going to be taking
out Hamas leaders I I I think if if
someone comes at you and attacks your
family you defend yourself and you stop
the threat the problem now is especially
with the bombing of this refugee camp
and the and the dead civilians the
collateral damage is becoming too great
and so uh I I actually I agree with AOC
I think AOC had a better answer than
Hillary she said a ceasefire goes both
ways we want Hamas to stop yeah and we
want Israel she she effectively said
Hamas needs to stop firing rockets at
Israel and Israel should go in and
assassinate Hamas leaders yeah
absolutely look if if uh if some cartel
members and from Mex Mexico came into
the United States and you know very uh
you know conspicuously killed 1400
people okay we would not bomb Mexico
okay we should use intelligence assets
to find those people and bring them to
justice not to bomb these civilians this
this is so Israel is turning the world
against them I mean look at all the
countries that are lined up now that
would that wanted to cease fire and how
many countries across the globe are
condemning Israel right now I mean it's
almost unanimous there's only a few out
uh hold outs you know what's interesting
about this conflict is that this is we
we are at the red how do you describe it
the threshold of Western
sensibilities in Warfare MH if you go
back 200 let's go back 300 years 300
years and I think youall are going to
know the answer to this what would
Nation a do to the people who were
conquered of that
land in in a situ like what what would
be happening if it was 300 years ago
that's a good question I I think it what
happened it's fairly obvious what I
think if it was 300 years ago yeah and
we were looking at Israel palestin as it
was today with the the the power of
Israel and what what Hamas is doing the
Israelis would go in and shove everyone
to the ocean and just Mass Purge and
kill everybody that's that's I shouldn't
say that absolutely because there are
many circumstances where countries did
not do this right but the ISS is as we
advance as moral civilized people we are
like hey we don't think it's good to
just go and just kill everybody right
but during the colonial period a lot of
that and so now this is what's
interesting you've got the left claiming
that Israel are the colonizers and they
must be resisted with decolonizing
things like that and if they really were
the colonizers that these the left is
claiming there are the colonizers of you
know of Y it would be Merc mercil it
would be brutal you don't think it's
merciless and brutal right now I think
no no no no no if if if you're saying
today is brutal then we we need a new
word for how brutal it would be if this
was 300 years ago uh 300 years ago there
were colonists in Africa they didn't
wipe everybody out what they did as for
we're talking about if we 300 years ago
had something akin to Gaza and Hamas and
Israel and a bunch of people stormed
into the the borders of a settlement and
massacred 1400 people the response from
the more powerful Nation would be a
Purge of everyone well I want to qualify
something about the 1400 by the way uh
there's there's pretty good evidence
that the IDF actually killed some of
these people now I am not saying this is
not hamas's fault but I'm and I'm not
exonerating OS but they bombed houses
that they thought were uh being where
people were being held hostage by
terrorists they bombed people on they
shot people on the street so I mean
there's a good number that were uh that
were taken out by the IDF uh and those
charred bodies that you saw in the media
those are not possible though that is
not possible Visa uh the uh do you have
a source I can pull up for for that
that's I've read it in five different
places Tim so I mean those are serious
claims I've not seen that you say that
Israel blew up their own Villages they
they blew up houses in which they
suspected the terrorists were holding
hostages but you need you need to know
your sources on that one if you're um
look at e uh Middle East
High we'll try and we'll try and pull
something like that up
mhm I don't I don't know how
uh yeah I don't
know I that's a bold claim I mean even
even some of the IDF forces said we
didn't know what we were shooting at we
didn't we didn't know and we just
started uh shooting randomly we didn't
know what to do because they were so
disorganized now I I would admit and
it's very true that the MOs caused a
great deal of confusion and through the
whole IDF into a complete uh quandry
they didn't know what was going on uh
and so they actually committed some acts
of violence against uh inadvertently
their own people you see this is why I
don't go anywhere near I think that's
not true I think what you're saying is
false I can't okay well we have to I'll
have to follow up with that right so so
this is I I take this is this is this is
the issue I take with the Israel paltin
conflict is all is all the lies and
misinformation that are spread all the
time and uh but you suspect I've heard
I've heard I've heard nothing about
Israel bombing its own villages we no
not whole Villages I did not say that
it's houses in villages houses I'm not
not saying they B accidentally shot
people on uh on the street and and that
just sounds like lies I mean and bombed
cars where the charred bodies were found
these were not this is not possible I
don't I believe it okay let let me ask
you this Tim like I'm saying it's not
possible what what would you think is
more likely the more powerful
propaganda that uh what's being told by
the mainstream media that uh and through
uh through coming out of Israel that
this is these are the truths or would
you think that it's more possible that
the propaganda is coming from the more
dominant forces propag is coming from
both however the left has a uh uh very
strong predis position towards
manipulation and lies and deceit well
I'm not a leftist no I know and so the
the issue is you don't have to be a
leftist to fall for leftist propaganda
we we debated the hospital bombing on
this show believing and and we should
not have because Hamas made a claim and
it wasn't true and now we know it's not
true because video emerged the next day
showing the parking lot I think it's I
think it's that's kind of it's frankly
that it's it's really a mood point
because of all the civilians they have
bombed they are killing K uh children
you know more children were killed in
three months or three weeks I'm sorry
three weeks this year that have been
killed in all wars uh from 2019 to now
not in each year there were like 2,000
children killed roughly 2019 20 2122 in
this three weeks they've killed three
over 3,00 is why I just say why are we
involved because I don't know why we're
arguing the morality of two factions
fighting a war and what the
justification is for arguing at all that
either side is better or worse I I agree
listen I'm not saying there's any good
guys here okay and I did read that claim
in a few sources and I I I don't have
the exact Source on on the tip of my
tongue but let me just say this it's
really immaterial
because you're right there is we don't
need to find the good guy and exonerate
one side over the other that's that's
not the
issue I just don't see that I to to you
know and that includes Israel by the way
because I think what they're doing if
they have a superior morality to the
people that they're killing then why
haven't they shown it well I I don't
think that I don't think that there's a
situation where where the United States
is going to be able to come to
a to a to a policy position that's going
to make anyone Happy Well it's not going
to be Utopia but it's got to be better
than what we've been doing I don't think
that I I don't know that I believe that
not not that I'm and again I'm not
saying that we shouldn't try or that we
should fund every time I I talk I have
to put this caveat because people are
going to start saying that oh you're
just pro Israel or whatever but that
that's not that's not what I'm saying
I'm just saying that I don't think that
whatever course of action the United
States takes is going to be sufficient
or have a substantive difference you
know what I mean a lot of history that
we frankly are besched with and that's
going to take that would take years to
actually dissipate and you know there's
there's not you know we can't take back
the fact of what we did in Iraq no that
that's that you're you're right but I
mean the the the tumultuous Middle East
goes back to the birth of our country
you know the very the reason we have the
Marine Corps is because of the barbery
Pirates off the coast of North Africa
that area is a show and it's always
been an absolute mess so the United
States can we can do our best to stay
out of the the political issues and and
tribal Warfare that happens in the
Middle East but I I don't know that
whatever course of action we take it
doesn't matter about like as as much as
this is not condoning the Iraq War but
the Iraq war is not why the people in
the Middle East you know hate us it's
it's that's not the reason not the
reason but it's one of them it's not the
reason it's not that we built bases in
Saudi Arabia it's not that Israel exists
it's been that way forever well I mean
according to Iraq that they attacked
Kuwait the first time because of our
bases in in Kuwait so I mean there is
because the bases in the in in Kuwait
and that was the reason for 911 as well
is because the Bas is in in the Holy
they looked at it like the United States
was conquering uh you know a part of
Saudi Arabia and I I understand that our
footprint is too broad that's the
problem so yeah it'll take a while to
wash off the the the the dirt that we've
been involved in but you know there's no
time like the president to start I again
I'm I'm not arguing that we shouldn't
what I'm saying is even if we take I
think that even if we take the course of
action that you believe is the or that
Libertarians believe is right and I
support not all Libertarians I do but
and and I support that course of action
I believe that that is a that would be a
good policy but I don't think that that
fixes the problems I think that as many
I think it's naive to think that that
that will solve problems eventually I
think that it's it's going to be a mess
over there I want I want to pull up this
video with this from clown world and uh
this is uh this is nothing unique it's
just another one of these videos where
we have far leftists tearing down
posters for the people who are kidnapped
and being held hostage yeah there's a
bunch of these videos there's another
video where a guy puts up a flyer for a
thae farmer not even an Israeli citizen
a guy who is just working in in Israel
who was kidnapped and this Asian woman
basically in front of him tears down his
flyer his property destroys it and then
basically tells him to screw off I see
these people and what they're doing this
is evil mhm this is this is this is
malicious intentional evil these people
think they're justified in causing harm
cast and destruction and so this is the
challenge I see when it comes to I don't
I don't I I don't care to get in the
history of the region we just talk about
literally October 7th you have people
Glide in kill a bunch of civilians Max
Blumenthal said it's because they see
civilians as targets of opportunity I'm
sorry specifically the music festival
was a target of opportunity and they
target civilians to use his bargaining
chips against the Israeli government I'm
like oh okay so they're
evil that's it right evil and uh what's
that you say the US has done really
horrible things in the Middle East hey I
never said we were the good guys I'm
saying right now we've got a crisis and
what happens is you see these people in
New York City defending Hamas cheering
on Hamas celebrating it they're now in
the United States they're in the west
there was this massive protest in London
this is why I don't believe anything
they said I I understand what you're
saying and let's talk about that story
and what's going on there what is that
being done what's being done here with
this uh imagery this is Despicable what
these people are doing okay but why has
this become news this has become news
because it it serves as a deflection it
serves as a deflection it says instead
of being angry about what's going on in
in uh the Gaza Strip what's happening to
people dying instead we're to we're
we're diverted into this uh this
particular uh you know uh despicable act
that takes the pressure off of Israel in
effect this works to this works as
propaganda but you know you but sure but
you know why this imagery is important
why why see I think it's very important
but what are they doing with it that's
the question these people these people
given the chance would kill you in your
sleep I don't know that I mean listen
I'm not sure what does decolonize mean
it means to get rid of the
colonizers how do you do that well I
mean but let's talk about what from from
The River To The Sea means well I agree
with that that's nonsense rhetoric and I
certainly would never uh use this is I'm
not saying you do I'm saying these
people have an extremist ideology it is
widespread in the west now and that's
the point I was making about Israel the
The Clash of warfare with and Western
sensibilities we as as Western liberal
nations are like we do not want to like
wipe out an entire people we want to
figure out how to stop the fighting and
then chill everybody the F out their
ideology is from The River To The Sea
yeah if if you even just walk through
what that means it's it's horrendous
they're talking about genocide but I
mean they're not they're not capable of
executing it okay so so the issue then
becomes Western sensibilities would say
act in such a way that allows them to
persist the people who would kill you in
your sleep and that's a liberal paradx
but right yeah exactly exactly that's
that's that's that's the The Clash of
Western sensibilities with modern
warfare if it were inversed and the
Israelis were were in the Gaza Strip
there is no question they would be
shoved into the ocean and mass executed
by by the Palestinians that's that's the
golden my a uh point but I I mean look I
don't I don't know about that I guess
we're going to have to judicate the
history in a little bit it's I'm not I'm
not here to to to talk about the the the
history of the region let's just we'll
remove Israel palestin from this if far
leftists like this are given power we
see what they do with it they kill
people well they do more than that they
they they also kill and torture yeah
they try to uh they try they're total to
itarian at base okay leftists are total
it's in it's intrinsic to leftist
ideology uh this is what they did in the
Soviet Union I mean once they gained
power leftists are totalitarian okay
they're for free speech they're for all
this when they're aspirant but once they
gain power they become like uh you know
Lenin and and Stalin and even then it's
not even necessarily that they're free
speech the Liberals are for free speech
I don't know if I would even I don't
know if there are any liberals where
where are the Liberals well we're here I
guess yes I guess classical liberal but
my point is this to to sort of move on
from the the the the broad topical
Israel Palestine but more into the
philosophical and ideological we are we
are confronted by right now um actually
we we can maybe pull this up in a little
bit Elon Musk saying the woke M virus is
destroying civilization you take a look
at San Francisco we'll go into DET he
was on Jan podcast but you take a look
at what the woke left represents and
what do you see 16-year-olds chanting
from The River To The Sea mhm they don't
know they don't care but they will do it
well this this isn't just you know look
I I admit and that's why I'm involved in
this and this is why I was asked to be a
candidate because I am I have been
involved in cultural uh issues and this
is a cultural War we we must fight in
the battle of ideas and so my my bigger
question is how do you win against a
group of people who you know want you
dead when you as a faction try to
preserve life right they have to they
have to be deprogrammed uh frankly have
to be deprogrammed that's not easy
almost impossible almost impossible in
this day and age in the age of the
internet when you cannot get them away
from a phone when you canot actually get
them out of the environment that's used
to it's not just the colleges it's not
just the high schools it's not just the
elementary schools it's the it's
everything they're getting on their
phone I don't think there's a liberal
solution because in order to pull
someone from like to to get someone to
leave a cult you have to remove them
from the cult can't remove them I got to
say it happened to me Tim I I mentioned
at the beginning of the show I used to
be a Marxist you know what did it for me
I was traumatized by them and that
caused my eyes to open once I was
traumatized by the left I then said this
this is a totalitarian uh contention
that I want nothing further to do with
at all and I instantly became a civil
libertarian this can happen they eat you
know the left eats its own but not not
quite fast enough I think that the the
attack the terror attack on the 7th did
a lot to wake a lot of Jewish liberals
up or or what a lot of liberals liberals
in general I've had several people who
definitely like who were very um very
much BLM in 2020 who started to at least
I I don't know if they were just getting
their news from different sources but
saw the stuff that Patrice Culler said
back in 2015 who are now seeing that
what you were sold in those in in those
early years in 2020 which everyone told
you said this is not what it is it's
look at what their website says look at
what all this information is they
weren't willing to listen they weren't
they were too filled with emotion at
that time and because it was scary the
the consequences of saying I am not for
black lives matter you know in 2020 if
you were not a staunch conservative that
had people around you that would support
that and that also agreed with you you
were not going to go out this is true
this happened with Co of course as well
these people effectively become State
agents uh these people that are walking
around telling get the mask on and
they're actually corralling you into the
state's propaganda and its
narrative no go ahead they have uh these
programs where this is like 10 15 years
ago you a company would ask you to go
out and write down license plate numbers
and where you saw them so that the state
and private companies could track down
the people and know where they were Mass
surveillance essentially snitch on your
neighbors but here's the scary thing
they don't need it anymore nope because
now you're you're carrying around a
tracking device everywhere you go yeah
you are so the the the the uh the main
issue I see with this is these videos of
them tearing down the poster I think are
extremely important the reaction from
the from the left cheering on Hamas even
right now these Mass protests in New
York uh uh and I say cheering on Hamas I
quite literally mean it I am not being
cute and conflating Palestine with Hamas
they're in New York bull horning in
support of Hamas calling them the
resistance fighters who fired x amount
of rockets and killed x amount of
settlers they say settlers are not
civilians how do you I mean is it is it
this is the
challenge how do you deprogram someone
when you cannot isolate them from the
information the challenge we face as
people who believe in you know civil
libertarian values the right of free
speech is that okay on a platform like X
or on Facebook or YouTube we're going to
let everybody speak what happens silos
emerge of far-left extremism we allow
that to happen then within that sphere
they start spreading oppressing and
crushing their opponents gaining more
and more power and silencing the rest of
us if we allow them the platform they'll
use it to destroy us they will not allow
us the platform so we we we have set
ourselves up at a at a in in a downward
slope as it were where where it seems
and this is why again Elon Musk we'll
pull that up in a second why he bought
Twitter to reverse this process but how
do you de like the the answer
programming these people ban Tik Tok
there you go ban Tik Tok regulate the
algorithms and mandate well might look
at the exactly does that you can't it
might supposed to expect that the US
government is going to be I don't want
the US government doing that so so the
problem is what would need to happen is
an organic pro-american you know o OG
ideological
faction canceling people and saying this
is the way we do things and if you are
communist or a fascist we don't we don't
sell to you we don't welcome you in our
stores well it's called yeah I mean this
this is very much of a a tradition
within libertarianism it's kind of a
joke you know uh physical removal of
Communists from our midst uh but let's
get back to the technology aspect if we
can the problem is not just that these
people are cultivated on the in these
Echo chambers that until musk bought
Twitter and I think musk is kind of a
Black Swan right now until he bought
Twitter the whole uh big digital social
media and search was all dominated by
leftism all the way down the line uh
Google for example is try de Googling
your phone yeah oh yeah yeah actually
let me pull the clip up from Elon and
then we'll we we'll carry on this is uh
Charlie Kirk has this tweet a year after
Elon Musk bought Twitter he finally
explains why he says that the niche
ideology that turned San Francisco into
a zombie apocalypse would historically
be geographically isolated and the
Fallout would therefore be limited but
Twitter gave that philosophy an
information technology weapon which it
could use to spread that mind virus to
the whole planet unopposed in order for
the Mind virus to propagate it must
suppress opposing viewpoints Rogan says
because it doesn't S scrutiny and musk
says correct I'll just play the clip for
you it's 2 minutes long youve you've
owned X for a year now a costume oh yeah
yeah you do you ever wake up in the
middle of the night and have a dream
that you didn't do
it and your life is infinitely easier
well it's certainly
um a recipe for trouble I suppose
or contention um what was it ultimately
that led you to make the decision to do
it I mean this is going to sound uh
somewhat melodramatic but I was worried
about that that it was having a
corrosive effect on civilization
uh that it was uh just having a bad a
bad impact it still is and
um I think part of it is that it's where
it's where it was located which is uh
you know downtown San Francisco um and
while I I think San Francisco is a
beautiful city and and we should really
fight hard to um kind of write the ship
of San Francisco if you've walked around
downtown San Francisco right near the
xfk Twitter headqu
it's a zombie apocalypse I mean it's
rough have you have you been been in
that area not lately no I've heard it's
crazy I've heard it's crazy I've heard
you you really can't believe it until
you actually go there you can't believe
it until you go there so now you have to
say well what philosophy led to that
outcome and that philosophy was being
piped to
Earth so um you know a philosophy that
would be ordinarily quite Niche and
geographically constrained so that that
sort of the Fallout uh area would be
limited um was effectively given an
information a
weapon um MH a tech Information
Technology weapon to
propagate uh what is essentially a mind
virus to the rest of Earth um and the
outcome of that mind virus is very clear
if you walk around the streets of
downtown San Francisco so I mean really
heits a nail in the head if you look at
San Francisco the human feces everywhere
the the ridiculous real estate prices
it's a it's a it's a wasteland of failed
policy but because so much information
control was centralized there
Information Systems it was piping that
that I would I would call it like feal
data yeah the the equivalent of feces in
data form into the brains of people and
it was just melting their brains and
tainting them with the Mind virus you
look at San Francisco and you can see
that ideology is
and has been popping up all over this
country he's he's Elon is trying to shut
down I still think he's got a long way
to go beyond that there's also just
failed governmental policy that plays a
huge role in that if we're looking at
Das who aren't Prosecuting violent crime
people who are uh like dep I'd actually
be interested to know what your position
is as a Libertarian is uh uh on go ahead
but this is this is be it's the policy
is because of social media it's it's
it's it's the ideology people getting
elected that it was it was the Free
Speech wing of the Free Speech party and
then it turned into a a campus safe
space for a bunch of whiny baby
Millennials but look at look at who's
opposing Elon Musk now uh he's getting a
he's gotten a lot of push back from the
woke cartel as I call it uh and one of
the major push backs he's getting is
from the ADL I mean he had to sue them
because they really wrecked his business
at the F in the beginning r ruining his
advertising base pulling all these
advertisers out now what that what is
that about so we're looking at this mind
virus uh is in the establishment and it
includes trying to squelch speech and it
includes critical discourse about some
very serious issues and groups like The
ADL that have all of this kind of power
in the system because they're
automatically perceived by anyone who
isn't aware of what's going on as a net
force for positive good in the world
when we know that it's been weaponized
time and time again against various
people who just happen to have ideas
that they disagree with so so you you
were a leftist professor yes I was and
you you broke out of this because you
said the left traumatized you yeah they
traumatized me what did they do um they
came after like I I started criticizing
all this social justice woke stuff on
campus for example they uh the the no
platforming you know the uh bias
reporting hotline that was a big one
they instituted this like reporting spot
system in which the students could
report on you for making a a woke
infraction you know what they call a
bias infraction and I thought it was
like a sty State system and I I spoke up
about it I would not put the the phone
number or the uh the email address on of
this biased reporting hotline on my on
my syllabi okay so they and then I I was
interviewed I started this uh Twitter
account it's now been cancelled uh
before uh Elon took over but I can't get
it back it was called anti-pc NYU Prof
and I started tweeting criticisms all
this from the standpoint of a professor
at NYU was interviewed and Twitter
banned you not yet not yet they did ban
it they eventually banned this profile
yes they did wow yeah and I haven't been
able to revive it even after elon's
takeover but then uh I did this
interview and I criticized all this
stuff publicly and within two days the
dean uh calls me into the office coerces
me into to a leave of absence the
diversity Equity inclusion group
condemns me I get a bunch of blistering
emails from faculty saying that I was uh
alt-right Nazi uh short pants white
devil all kinds of ludicrous things
racist sexist the whole nine yards
anti-gay now today I would just you know
what I'd write back is
LOL but then I actually cared what these
people thought just remember the people
tearing down the people tearing down
those photos of the Israelis were to
actually be the ones calling you a Nazi
probably back then so yeah they would
well so at the time what did you do you
wrote an apology or something oh no no I
started I wrote Springtime for
snowflakes for one okay and I stood up
to them and uh I eventually sued them I
sued NYU and five professors that were
libeling me all through the uh official
NYU list serves and eventually they said
you know they settled with me you know
how I got them to settle you'll love
this uh they threw out the uh Mo they
filed a motion to dismiss the case and
my lawyers could not overtake this uh
huge Army of attorneys that NY you had
so I invited Milo eanop to speak in my
classroom listen to this on Halloween
itself okay and the topic of the of the
talk was going to be how you're not
allowed to wear a Halloween costume for
one night but you can change your gender
by day okay that was the topic and they
shut it down guess this B deasio
intervened and shut down my classroom
himself whoa yeah how how did what did
he do police he called NYU and said this
is too dangerous for to take place now
of course we know the danger was coming
from antifa who actually put a Target on
my back and threw Twitter were
threatening to kill me wow I've been
told that antifa is not even a real
thing it's not even a real oh it's just
an idea it's just an idea it's an idea
that's in a lot of people's heads to
make them act like antifa to to what you
said though like what you went through
kind of of circles the point of what
you're saying is like if you push back
most people don't have the resources to
go against groups like this which have
massive budgets endowments whole groups
you know cers of lawyers to back up this
prob I touched the third rail that there
was significant power behind that and I
realized at that point that this social
justice or what we now call wokeness was
really the power this was embedded in
the power structure if everybody who is
uh currently facing a a criminal uh
proceeding pleaded not guilty the system
would collapse really yeah the system
relies on uh people taking plea Bargains
and so that's that's why they the system
in my view is completely
unconstitutional it's the are you
familiar with the jury tax or the trial
tax people call different things the
idea being that they will always say to
you whatever whatever it is you've
committed you're getting the maximum
right you know it's like oh you you uh
you were speeding that's you know you
were going 20 you going 30 over the
limit that's that's felony territory
you're getting a year in prison and
we're going to make sure that when
you're convicted you get it or plead
guilty accelerates the process so they
could funnel more people through because
they don't it's impossible to act well
it's because nobody wants to do the work
and so this is a huge failure of our
system it's supposed to be difficult and
expensive to make sure we uphold justice
but you see we got a lot of people who
don't want to deal with it they're lazy
I don't know you I don't care used to be
that if a cop stopped you and I mean
like early days of cops people knew the
cop in their neighborhood or yet a
sheriff you know or a constable I guess
and they knew people and and social
scrutiny played a role in whether or not
they would be abusive most cops don't
even live in the area absolutely and so
when uh Co happened and a tilla's gym
stayed open the local cops said have a
nice day everybody so they pulled in
cops from a different city who said we
are now going to start putting the boot
on your neck yeah this is why I in my
campaign is a promotion of localization
and
decentralization to rest control from
this central government vested in the
people at the local level and then
nullify unconstitutional laws and
mandates that are coming down yeah how
many departments cabinet level
departments would you get rid of if you
want cabinet oh that's that's nice I get
to the cabinet level departments after I
get rid of the IRS the CIA the ATF the
uh the FBI uh of course the FED there we
go Etc the first one the fed the FED is
obviously the big monster okay but it's
not as easy to get rid of as as just go
in and acts it you have to get an act of
Congress but in the meanwhile we can
erode its power by promoting parallel
currencies Bitcoin Etc uh and that means
you rest the power away from this money
monopolist and you use currencies on
your own in the local communities or
across communities this roads their
power base as a
monopolist I like
this endorsed thank
you you well all right huh I said well
I'll right then I'll right that you see
all the memes that have been going
around for like uh all the Libertarians
dad Libertarians in Halloween it says
like me uh it's a it's a picture of Ron
Paul says when I implement the dad tax
on my son's Halloween candy and he
slowly turns into Bernie
Sanders yeah let's uh let's uh I guess
we'll just talk about Ronda Sanders's
boots
again made for walk not for the Sant has
this been happening every night or just
the nights I'm on here it feels like
every time I'm on we're talking about
okay well look it's because Donald Trump
has chimed in and said this is the kiss
of death for Rhonda santis and uh this
you know look Ashley stclair I'm I'm
look let me slow down you know how we
have these really awesome quotes from
the founding fathers and you'll you'll
like look in a book and you'll be like
reading about some crazy dude in the
16th century and he'll say something
like the the king here nearby declare
through Divine Providence means as much
Declarations of Divine Providence mean
as much to me as the manure of a horse
and you're like wow like look how bold
now it's like that was because when they
wrote things down it was rare they
talked a lot of smack but they rarely
wrote things down so when they did they
really thought them through MH now
you're going to have quotes from people
in the history books that just like I
got some quotes for you man like if you
go through my Twitter and pull up some
of the people are going to be like what
like you know like posting pictures like
someone's going to like I posted a
picture of a hairless rabbit once for no
reason yeah and it's like you couldn't
imagine the fing fathers doing I mean
you could they would be silly sometimes
like Ben Franklin was known to be to
have s of humor but so now we're looking
at the story about Ronda sandis and his
and his and his high heels of course he
is absolutely I think it's proven at
this point Beyond a reasonable doubt
he's wearing high heels he's been
convicted in Shoe Court in public court
well because there's that video where
he's walking and and it it you know his
foot doesn't exist it folds straight I
saw the interview off the my point yes
and and who says that my point is this
the history books are going to are going
to say what I don't know what date was
but like you know in in October of 2023
Ashley stclair posted a video making fun
of the Ronda sandz campaign and putting
on thigh high cowboy boots the which
which generated a response from from
Ronda sanz's PR team this led to a
larger conversation on the timcast
podcast finally a statement from the
president from the from the front runner
for the Republican party on his his
rival wearing high heeled boots this is
what the history books are going to say
in such an unserious time it's
unbelievable it is unserious in a sense
yeah but it feels like a sitcom episode
where like he's going around and they're
like you're wearing high heels like
they're not heels they're lifts and he
has to keep correcting people dystopian
dark comedy though I'm okay with it
though why didn't they stuff his boots
like look at this
picture like guys take some toy Pap
they're even too long not only are they
too high they're too long what what is
this so just pick them
up too long because his foot's pulled
back on
a so so and then a lot of people are
pointing out when he said uh they're off
the rack lucazi boots people are like
who says off the rack no he hadn't seen
like oh I haven't seen this I'm like
you've seen this bro don't anyway anyway
the point is the point is
Donald Trump chiming in and uh do we
have the uh I think the post millennial
had let me let me let me pull up the
post-millennials version because they I
think they actually have the statement
from Donald Trump I guess The Daily
Beast didn't have the statement they
just mentioned that Donald Trump chimed
in I don't know whatever let me see I
think uh what do we got here we go Trump
campaign responds to boot gate calls it
the kiss of death Kellin is claiming
boot gate is his Kell bootate Kell is
claiming that that's his term that he
came up with boot things a scathing new
article from Politico about Ron D
sanon's high heeled shoes comes on the
heels of an embarrassing interview on
the Patrick Bet David show that led to
boot gate trending on X when asked
directly about why his boots look like
stilts desanctis offered up the
implausible explanation that he just
wears off the rack lucazi boots doing
major brand damage to a great American
footwear company oh yeah did some brand
damage all right this this is why Trump
wins against dis santis at least because
that's the kind of funny statement like
a side joke where it's like you accuse s
of of of bmer merching the good name of
liesi he says if there is any
enterprising journalist willing to
contact the liesi Press team for their
thoughts on desanctis they're reachable
here and then he Le to it in another
moment of insanity Rond off wrote the
laughable claim that he's 5'11 instead
of telling the truth and just being
comfortable in his own skin he resorts
to borderline psychotic behavior by
lying to the American people is that
what this country wants in a president
Okay blah blah this is not from it's
it's Stephen Chong Trump spokesperson
but I just want to say I think Ronda
santis is the dumbest politician I've
seen in my life the dumbest um look
policy wise did some good stuff I'm now
going to chalk it up to the Florida
State Legislature a large body of
individuals pushed forth a bunch of
ideas and Ron said okay sounds good and
he's getting all the credit for it Ron
has got to be the dumbest guy in
politics because he's had every
opportunity after every single blunder
and failure he won't fire these guys he
won't fire his PR team it's almost like
he's doing it on purpose maybe Ron's the
smartest guy in politics and I can't
understand why it is he would destroy
himself in this way or he's just really
really dumb he's dumb but let's let's
talk about how unfortunate it is that
our political discourse has as and I
don't want to come off as the pendant
and the uh former Professor etc etc but
look at the depth to which our discourse
has sunk if we can't win in the realm of
ideas we have to resort to Boots and
boot gate boot gate it was look it's
Halloween this was the trending story
this morning when I wake up I'm like are
you kidding me it's like a 100,000
tweets boot gate boots Trump it's
accessible to everyone it is kind of
what has turned politics into a bit of a
spectator team sport which team I I
admit that it's is it necessarily the
greatest thing for America for America
as a whole no but I have a lot of fun
with it doesn't bother me it's fun I
wish it was like a cartoon instead of
reality but I was uh recently recently
Gren Glenn Greenwald was on uh Jordan
Peterson's podcast and one of the things
that they were talking about was people
today with the with the kind of the the
fact that religion became less important
in communities and less important to
Americans people replaced religion with
essentially what boils down to State
worship it's not quite that but but
that's that's essentially the effect um
and I think that's probably the biggest
problem that we have in the US now I'm
I'm an agnostic I don't particularly
have a religion that I you know that I
I'm I'm more uh more you know more
likely to to be supportive of or
whatever but I don't think that we have
the option to not have a religion people
there's a lot of people that get it in
their head that humans should just
evolve past religion and they just don't
have any idea that they don't have any
idea how Evolution works if that's what
they think because it takes an outside
force for there to be Evolution religion
is ubiquitous across Humanity whether no
matter what Society you you you look at
every society no matter how far they are
part in distance or in time every
society that that has had human's been
created by human beings has had some
kind of religion with it religion is as
Inseparable from H from The Human
Experience and from Psychology from
Human psychology as I think as humor or
as any other interpersonal relationship
it's probably a psychological phenomenon
built to deal with our own to deal with
be having the motivation to Keep Us
Alive and at the same time connect well
no at the same time dealing with the
fact that we are finite and going to die
real quick I was thinking a lot about
this earlier and I was thinking about uh
Kirt Cain and I was thinking about um
who was I thinking about just a bunch of
musicians who who've killed themselves
and I was just like how is it that
someone like Kurt Cobain okay maybe it's
not a good example because there's
conspiracy theories around whether or
not he actually kill himself but there
are many uh rock stars MH who uh you
know what I was thinking of I was think
of Matthew Perry and uh uh he's found
underwater in his hot tub drowning
Cardiac Arrest depends on the reports
and a lot of people said look man this
is a guy who did a lot of drugs in his
day and was like pretty messed up and
depressed for a while right is that just
yeah and also hot tub when with any
heart condition is a nogo not a good
idea so so I started thinking this like
how could you be on the show Friends the
biggest show and like still one of the
biggest shows ever making how much were
they making per episode was like a
million bucks more than that like yeah
several million dollars and then resort
to doing drugs I'm like how do you
that's the norm but no but no no no but
but I I think I get it how come Elon
Musk is the world's richest man and is
not doing drugs and not drinking purpose
and exactly so for for if you're a
regular dude and you're funny and then
someone says would you like to be funny
in my show and you're like sure and
every day you struggle every day you're
trying to figure out how to pay the
bills every day you're waking up
figureing out how you're going to pay
your rent and then one day some someone
says make this joke on TV you do boom
biggest show in the world all of a
sudden you have no struggle all of a
sudden you are loaded with cash you have
nothing to do you don't have to worry
for anything and you've never you've
never had a strong purpose your purpose
has always been to survive but now you
don't have to whereas Elon musk's
purpose is Advance Humanity in the ways
he wants to so what's what what's
missing I believe and always it just
Roots down to one simple thing for many
people religion yeah yeah and think uh I
think the point was made that you know
statism has become a religion and and
this was the case and identity polic
that's how they they fight the
depression right there you've got these
young women that are chock full of crazy
pills you know the most irritating thing
to me is when I hear like some
Millennial woman be like he needs a
Xanax or like I take a Xanax like no
stop doing these things well look I'm
not going to tell you what to do your
doctor prescribes it you do what your
doctor says but I'm just like it's
insane that people are like well better
take a mood stabilizer they tell
everybody else to get therapy not
realizing that it's not necessarily for
everybody it's we've medicalized a lot
of the world today to act to your point
with actors I think a lot of it also has
to do with the fact that they have a a
very dangerous combination of both
insanely High Egos and extremely uh
sensitive personalities because uh the
profession as a whole requires you to be
very much vulnerable all the time which
leads to heavy drug use for a lot of
them and I think that's true of a lot of
what's going on in American culture
right now is there's a lot of uh there's
a lot of depression there's a lot of
sadness and people it could be that
they're not filling it with religion
like they did in the past and the people
that are filling it with what we would
call now identity politics or the state
as a religion are being fed uh an IDE an
ideological means of hatred State a
failed religion EST statism is a failed
religion it will not sustain you like if
you want if we're talking about marxists
telling you who have been told you
you've been raised to hate your country
you've been raised to hate people that
are that see the world differently than
you while being told that they're
oppressing you even though that dude's
as poor that that dude is as poor and as
and as miserable as you are how is that
not a world of depression and sadness
for people and it gives you a sense of
moral superiority dang allows you it
allows you to to oppress people to act
violently the whole punch a Nazi thing
it's like as soon as as soon as as soon
as the argument was it's acceptable to
punch a Nazi everybody became a Nazi
because it was just whoever I want to
punch as a Nazi that's the excuse is
your so it gives people the excuse to
behave terribly to behave with
aggression and and and Malice towards
other people and feel like they are they
are doing the morally correct thing and
that's I forget who it was but someone
someone quoted that that's the most
delicious of psychological treats to be
able to abuse someone and feel like
you're doing it as a good thing and if
you look at the the jihadis the the the
Islamic terrorists that's what they all
do they all believe that they're the
they are in the right and if they beat
the crap out of an Infidel God wanted
them to so that was a moral thing throw
gay people off a building it doesn't
matter because God wanted it you can be
as atrocious to people that don't
believe in your religion as you want
because God has said it and it's the
same type of attitude from the marxists
and the farle when they're saying oh
well beat the Nazis another thing about
wokeness as a religion it it's it's you
know unlike Christianity There's No
Redemption under worldless right so if
you're white and you know male you're
you're you're damned for for eternity
there's no way out and uh you know going
back to your point about religion uh
anthropologists have suggested they you
know why religion is so U durable is
because it actually came at the same
time as civilization as we got into uh
creation and you know creativity
Innovation Etc it it sprouted at that
exact same moment so it's no surprised
that it's it's so uh it's so
recalcitrant for some or otherwise you
might say it's very uh
it's it's a you know a kind of permanent
part of the human life and I'm agnostic
as well but imagine the hubris of like
just now in this time period feeling
like you found the answer that every
generation in the past didn't need the
the the atheist movement in the early
2010 probably did more damage to America
than it's it's it's exhausting I I do
love these like 18-year-old leftists who
think they've discovered universal truth
that no one else has ever has ever
thought of and like they just have not
read yeah any philosophers yeah I was 18
for once too I think a lot of it is like
in the age of the internet like the the
ease of access to information and this
is something that I think we're all at
least somebody like me is guilty of as
well and have to like put myself in
check like knowing something isn't the
same thing as understanding it like and
you have access to a lot of information
and then you have people believing that
they know better than somebody who's
practical in their field and that's just
not the way the world works right yeah
you have to actually live things and
experience things to have real knowledge
it isn't something you can impart
through just information per se yeah um
yeah I don't know it's uh all of it is
very like that is the most depressing
like of all the conversations we just
had that might be the most depressing
like all the war and everything but it's
like everything that's going on I find
like what's gone on in the last cuz it's
like it's been so quick in the last 12
to 15 years the the shift in American
values in the last 15 years has been so
abrupt but why is that shift happening
because Millennials are entering the
workforce so it was a crazy moment for
me when I used to play shows as a
teenager I'd go to a cafe and I'd play
an open mic and then one day I turned 21
and when I used to play shows as a
teenager everyone at the shows was
always between the ages of like 16 and
20 cuz as soon as you turned 21 you're
at the bars so I turned 21 and I'm like
I'm going to find an open mic and I'm
like oh here's one I'm like I'd go to
open mic.com and I'm like oh it's a bar
I show up everyone's 40 and I was like
whoa this is kind of weird like I've
never experienced this all of a sudden
it was like the training wheels come off
and welcome to the real world the entire
bar is full of people of all different
there's like several decades here of
different values different worldviews I
had now at that point entered that this
adult space for the first time playing
shows with people with tremendous way
more experience way more opinions more
knowledge more wisdom some stupid people
don't get me wrong and so what happens
is we're like how did it how did the
world how did how this country changing
it's not that people are becoming woke
it's that young people were
indoctrinated to be woke and now they're
old enough to have an influence in the
marketplace yeah in politics there's a
white pill I'd like to drop on all this
is I think I I do think there's going to
be a a Renaissance of uh liberty-minded
people that's going to come out of this
movement uh because they as you pointed
out it's a path to you know destruction
destitution uh economically socially it
leads to you know uh decadence and and
uh there's going to be a renaissance of
L of of liberty-minded people coming out
of this woke contagion I hope that's
true but I'm going to be honest like
like when I the the number one place
where I see this topic is when people
talk about the housing market when they
talk about the price of housing how so
many young people are being PR you know
the your parents say go to college you
like oh you went to college in a
part-time job blah blah blah we see
these these very very Doomer
descriptions that are accurate they're
accurate to World we're living in right
now but I don't think that creates
people who want free markets because
they've been poisoned to believe that
the free market a is a is a but I think
we're going to it's going to create
Communists and it's going to create
socialists yeah but they're going to
they're going to experience the misery
that that brings and that's we're all
going to experience we all are and then
we're going to have to fight our way out
we have to fight our way out we get that
before we get to before we get back to
Liber I mean it's going to be San
Francisco time 10 everywhere that's
depressing unless I'm not I'm not not
I'm not convinced that it gets to a
communist Soviet style ex no I think I
think we may already be out of the Tail
Spin and starting to pull back if you
look at budlight sponsoring UFC we all
kind of groaned when they did but now
you see Sean Strickland being like Oh
yeah let's see how budl responds to this
dude getting up on stage with a Bud
Light in hand saying a whole bunch of
anti-woke and defensive things to make
the point budlight is forced to back him
now and back his speech and his speech
is not favorable towards trans people
even if the tide is turning and you
might be right about the tide turning
even if it is this is something that is
going to take a while to get out of the
schools because there are people that
are going to fight like hell and there's
also industry that's already built in
got people with tenure that aren't going
to want to give up their jobs you've got
you've got school they as long as
they're in schools and they're teaching
kids these things kids are going to be
coming out of schools and you have 20
years of of graduating classes that
believe this crap but I but what I'm
saying is two things first we we we've
part of the movement has already been to
criticize schools in general for
everything they are not just be like oh
there's winess in schools no it's not
right like schools are bad homeschool
your kids exactly but then also if young
if if if you go on Twitter if you go on
X if you go on Instagram you go on these
platforms and you have the wrong opinion
you're made fun of you don't get
followers if the shift among prominent
popular people and celebrities is
against the wokeness now especially
because of Israel yes these young look
I've told this her before when I went to
VidCon in like 2016 and uh I'm walking
as I'm walking in I see these group of
kids probably 13 years old and one kid
goes you have 80 followers how do you
have 80 followers wow and like these
little kids are growing up in a world
where follower count matters and that's
going to warp their brains in crazy ways
but guess what if you're in high school
and you're like I want a million
followers and then you see all all the
celebrities are getting behind Israel
and opposing the left right and now you
get Amy Schumer retweeting or posting on
Instagram campus reform which is a more
right-leaning
Outlet now these young people are like I
want a million followers I want to be a
celebrity and they're going to go in
this that's right I think I've said this
in my book great reset in a struggle for
Liberty we need defection from the
elites we're always going to have Elites
there's a natural Elites you know not
just those that are propped up by the
state and other artificial measures but
we need defectors and you know perhaps
Elon Musk has one we need other
defectors from the elite and yes you
could be right and pull you know so give
people somebody to you know we need
public voices that that come out against
all this and that will be a big part of
this and I hope to make my campaign part
of that and that is to you know be
publicly stating these things undoing
the Mind virus is there like a primary
for the libertar yeah there is a primary
when is it it's ongoing now oh it's on
going now oh yeah it goes well see we we
have a convention in May and that
convention that's where the candidate is
chosen by delegates delegates yes it's
not an open voting system it's a
delegate selection system that doesn't
sound very
libertarian I know that what you mean to
say is that doesn't sound Democratic but
um libertarianism and democracy are kind
of there's a tension there be real about
that yes yeah because actually democracy
in in in its extremes it Ines property
rights 100% okay so you know three out
of four say your your your money is mine
uh you know there you go you can rob
that guy so but kind system but I do
kind of feel like you know just start
from the ground if if you are a
Libertarian the question is why does
anyone have authority over me right good
question and so no nobody do as
Libertarians we don't think you we
should have authority over here so why
am I running for office is that where
you're going no why why is it a at based
system that's determining who gets to be
the nominee why why why does the party
have the authority over over my choice
in who should be the nominee who should
be uh yeah yeah I mean to be to be fair
it's because the party is giving them
the backing basically yes that's so so
the party is choosing at least it's
honest about it look at the Democratic
party what they're going to do right
what well what they were going to do to
Kennedy for example and they made it
very clear it didn't matter how many
votes he got they were going to give it
to uh to Biden or whoever they Biden
whoever they stand up Biden needs to be
the nominee I don't think he will be
though whoever they stand up yeah I me
if they can stand him up you know long
enough to uh Gavin Gavin Newsome met met
with Xin ping because he knows he sees
the runting on the wall same as
everybody else it's not going to be
Biden feels like Gavin Newsome like the
more the more that I see about it yeah
there's there's a lot of play out there
even when you see conservative women
being like I hate his guts but the guy's
handsome you're just like man this like
he definitely has like an an evil
quality about him look around Los
Angeles take a look around San Francisco
look at the
outrageous destitution and horor that
this this guy's policies have brought to
this to this state we've talked about
how the way to remove Joe Biden is like
the perfect scenario for the Deep state
is Joe Biden suffer some kind of medical
issue Gavin Newsome runs on Biden's at a
ra a rally in California and then hasp
grips his chest and then Gavin usam Runs
Out performs CPR saves the life of the
president KLA Harris steps in as acting
president but says she she does not want
to start a campaign this late in the
season she wants to do her duty to this
country Gavin Newsome then says I will
do it goes on every Al on the Press
store but what if what if it's just
something crazy like Joe Biden
sacrifices himself in some really crazy
way like bringing peace to the Middle
East or whatever he personally goes
there and like walks on the battlefield
and holds up his hands and then they're
like no Joe and then he goes down in
history as like the Savior that's how
they get rid of him yeah but I'd be
happy very surprised about that he's
going to eat an ice cream cone too fast
and die of a of a brain freeze sniffing
someone's hair by the edge of a mountain
and he just Falls right now this guy's
just a a prop I mean he's a
ventriloquist dummy there's nothing
there also to your point you know but
but I think it's fair to say more of
like um I don't know if ventriloquist
dummy is the right right phrase because
he's also sort of this vacuous pit for
moneya laundering yeah that's true you
know yeah yes that's that's true he has
kind of a money in his um in his
puppetry maybe he's a Pneumatic banking
tube where where the government can put
the money and then it yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's true good point to to what
you were saying Phil also about the you
were mentioning the schools but also the
companies the corporations where all of
these policies have been enacted and are
now enshrined it's going to take an
inordinate amount of time to get that
removed from their what they call
mission statements or their company
values which is I still laugh maybe more
funny than anything else is the idea
that a corporation has like a mission
statement or has values but you know
you've got you've got mid-level uh
mid-level employees with hiring
capabilities that have been
indoctrinated with these viewpoints who
have been shoveled this stuff for the
last two decades you're not just going
to have to get rid of them you're going
to have to get rid of the the people
under them them I don't think there's a
lot of conflict between my point and
what Tim says I'm just talking I'm
thinking that it's just going to take
time to actually get this stuff out it
didn't happen overnight it happened
quickly because of the internet and
stuff but it didn't happen overnight
know if it's that it happened quickly
it's that they they plac the chess
pieces over a long period of time thato
and then and then the internet just
allowed the game to move faster there
there's something else inv involved with
wokeness it's it's not just cultural or
ideological it is actually economic and
they're actually they've seized upon
this as a means for establishing what I
call a woke cartel and that is to get
rid of businesses by virtue of saying
look if you don't get uh Larry thinkink
says Larry thinkink of black Brock if
you you don't if you don't live up to
this ESG now he's changed the name of it
cuz it's got such a bad name if you
don't live up to this ESG we're not
going to invest capital in you so this
is kind of a cartel scheme on top of all
the cultural stuff uh wokeness is kind
of like a a demarcation device to to
siphon Capital uh to the right players
and get rid of the rest true I think a
big component of it was creating
division amongst the working class as it
pertains to the populist Uprising with
Bernie and Trump they they're like uh oh
you Occupy Wall Street that's a scary
thing you got a bunch of people
complaining about big bank bailouts what
do we do yeah make them complain about
the race of the other person and that's
what happened mostly the Left Right the
right didn't go racist the they did not
no but I think both sides took the bait
and they fight about it back and forth
non-stop I think everybody ends up
taking make we are complaining about
wokeness because wokeness is a bad thing
the left took the bait and became woke y
oh yeah and uh I think it was used I'll
sorry just real quick I'll put it this
way you you you've got two two guys that
are teaming up against you know the big
fat cat so the big fat cat throws you
know like some coyotes into your room
and then all of a sudden you're like now
we have to deal with these coyotes MH
you know they're a
problem yes wokeness is a distraction
but it's not something that we can
ignore no it has to be fought directly
I'm just think like 2020 when George
Floyd happened and you have black lives
matter and then you have the people
saying all lives matter and then they
fight about what that means for the next
eight months right that's a distraction
but both sides ended up taking the bait
because both sides felt like they had a
right to have their opinion heard and
neither side felt like the bad guy
except that the doj made one side the
bad guy they made you yeah they told us
that the biggest threat to our country
was white supremacist and as domestic
terrorists and a lot of times like like
to me I believe a lot of the people who
took into this IDE on Facebook who
weren't necessarily the most politically
inclined but buy into the slogan right
that's why the slogan is so effective
give it good name you know good company
we're we're the good company why would
you not support good company right you
buy into that so the average person
who's just working his 9 to-5 job who
just wants to support other people he
doesn't realize that he's being used as
a pawn by these companies and making it
impossible for people to have honest
discourse yeah all right let's go to
super chats if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and head over
to
timcast.net
should the left win Clinton has already
teased what they're thinking well World
War
I the bonus hole says if you don't fall
o uh oh if you don't follow the bonus
holes on X Kathleen Kennedy will crawl
out from under your bed and release a
rebooted version of the OG Star Wars
Trilogy and she'll replace Vader with a
chick and make her gay happy Halloween
did you did you watch the panda verse no
was it good I I loved it oh really I
should watch it it was they they end up
criticizing Kathleen Kennedy and the
people that criticize Kathleen k but
it's done in a way that's pretty good
Trey Parker and Matt Stone are are
pretty are pretty good at that still
yeah everyone everyone gets it I mean
cuz Cartman is always the standin for
because Cartman is the anti-woke person
he's still the standin for that lets you
know a little bit of what they think of
you but also what they think of Kathleen
Kenny but she goes and she finds the
Pander Stone in the depths of Disney I
saw that clip yes it's it's it rips open
a hole into like the Multiverse
something the layers of irony are wild
like the the human brain can't can can't
fathom the the Multiverse cuz the idea
they're making fun of how the Multiverse
is stupid and it's like Randy's just in
the Multiverse and all that's happening
is his clothes is changing he's like oh
my God I'm wearing a dolphin's Jersey oh
my God I'm wearing a giant like it's
it's really really funny good all right
let's grab another one waffle sense he
says the disantis heels gate it's boot
Gate scandal is the most attention Ron
has had in months it's actually all
coordinated to get his name in the press
this is for D chess boys and girls strut
your stuff Little D the world is
watching tiny D maybe he just wants a
boot SP I say one of the things this
boot gate is uh diverting attention from
is the weird fact that the sis sends
from Florida arms and Aid to Israel
except weapons yes including citizens
weapons who they you know who were giv
up now whether they are allowed in or
not is another question but desis is
actually arming Israel himself wow if
I'm not going to get to be president I'm
going to do this before just in case
yeah I'm going to act presidential send
arms over now NE conron right Neo conron
Juan Castle says Baha Tim Po where is
your count chocula costume nobody's
nobody's dressed up no no one's dressed
up I'm just dressed as me a thought
criminal we had we had multiple like
Halloween topics to like best I can do
it's Tuesday though that's the challenge
like if Halloween's on a weekend then
people past weekend yeah yeah everybody
uh I saw a lot of people when I in
Pittsburgh trick-or-treating on oh yeah
that was big time that night y yeah so
it was like they'll have
trick-or-treating on the weekend or
something I was in Hager toown and there
was like a parade going on and I was
like oh this is kind of wholesome
there's all these families out with
their kids that was great until it was
like impossible to get out of Hagerstown
trying to drive around the parade all
right Eric Max says Tim are you
recording the process of building the
coffee show because people do like
watching that kind of thing we're not
that actually would be a really people
love that type of stuff
just like how to build a Cofe shop just
like yeah like you could even do like
weekly updates like I mean there's
people here with cameras just simply
like go out grab some b-roll of what's
going on talk to whoever's in charge and
get like a two to three minute update on
what they've done this week and posted
on te cast.com the reason I think that
the economy is collapsing and the end is
n is because of how difficult it is to
do simple things oh the red tape is
insane for everything it's not even red
tape it's the inability of contractors
and companies to
function we've got a bunch of people
being like my company people don't how
to do anything it's not it's not just
that it's that the system is completely
broken so when we get hit up by company
saying they can do the job and then it's
like eight eight weeks go by and they're
like why haven't you started and they're
like well we didn't get the permit yet
yeah and then uh and then there's some
kind of error or problem and then it's
delayed again we we got a frog pond
installed and we were like expedited
they're like we'll come out this weekend
a month later it was done now a pond is
a really simple thing they dig a hole
they line it and they put rocks around
and a filter and it took a month to do
what was supposed to be a weak project
and I'm like I think the world is
collapsing yeah it's pretty bad man
people can't you know we've got a kind
of dysfunction in the system because
people have been uh you know they've
abdicated all these rules to the state
and so they don't know how to do
anything anymore we need to resume
taking over our that's the other story
line and it is the story line is that
all of the handymen in South Park are
billionaires now because because of
nobody knows how to do anything so all
their jobs have been so it's talking
about taking down the billionaires and
it's just these two handymen who are
both just insanely Rich because nobody
knows how to do anything yeah oh all
right bowmani says uh they find it funny
how Tim has armed security fled to West
Virginia hides on a compound obscures
his address hasn't not worn his beanie
in years I haven't wor my beanie since I
was I I haven't I've always worn the
beanie prob go back go back and look at
the photos when I was 14 in
skateboarding yet calls his financial
supporters cowards wait for the cope
when did I call my financial supporters
cowards that that literally never
happened but I'm more than willing to
read your fake criticism it's amazing
what people say you know outrageous
things that they have no basis for just
Mak they just make up make up
constantly yeah but uh we'll break it
down uh armed security you bet I also
have a bunch of guns myself why would I
not have security do you have people
threatening to kill you all the time
sometimes if you go out into public
antifa maybe but like do people send
bombs and and bomb threats to your house
so why wouldn't I have armed security
fled to West Virginia why would I want
to live in New York or California I went
to a place where I could push back the
wokeness where we are in the Panhandle
in West Virginia you've got woke people
trying to move in we're pushing them out
we're going to be building an anti-time
square and helping to uh secure
Americans values hides on a compound I
love everyone calls this a
compound single office building yeah I
mean I'm not going to give anything else
away also like obscuring your address
like yes my my my 50 acres in New
Hampshire is the compound so it's like
bro obscure as my address are you now
going to post in the chat your address
yeah really they want you to dox
yourself yeah right yeah and then
literally you're doing a you're doing
localization and you're doing
decentralization and you're doing it in
real life this is what we need it is the
weirdest thing though how people call
this a compound and it's like if we if
we bought a building in the city they'd
call it an office but you buy a building
outside the city and they call it a
compound and I'm like okay now makes you
sign like David KES exactly yeah like
the the point is they have the the
people who are trying to tear down uh I
think I think it's fair uh All is fair
in Love and War the left needs to lie
because that's the only way they can win
yeah so for instance Phil is a failed
musician according to S perer despite
having multiple gold records and a
platinum record coming out with new
music and like opening for Metallica
quite literally the the Hallmarks of
success yeah but they have to lie about
it that's also why he didn't say his
name they claim I don't know how to
skateboard well we got a whole buch of
Cs we got we got a couple Clips I could
put up I just didn't even upload them
Richie Richie uh comes in and he's like
hey Tim do a switch Tre flip and I'm
like all right I guess first try switch
Tre flip no problem they have to lie
it's also a ridiculous criticism that
has nothing to do with this here no the
the the idea of claiming that Phil is
not successful or I'm not successful is
because they don't want young people to
look up to us that's what the most
abolutely that's the thing it's a
compound it's like well it's a giant
mansion with a mini ramp in the basement
a skate park outside but it's just one
big building yeah but however freed
dastan is 50 acres that's compound but
but what does compound mean
they what they're trying to suggest yeah
you've got arms in here and you're
basically barricaded behind walls
they're trying to claim as like yeah
there's a big fence keeping people out
and everyone lives here like nobody the
feds should come after you too that's
the other thing Su us right
mhm all right well I'll tell you this
the building that we have at freedan is
a big uh sterile white building like it
like any other office building so there
you go they'll love that yeah they'll be
like okay well it's a regular office
building I guess I like that Tim guy now
he's
great all right what do we got we'll
read some more Super chats CVA Buck says
last night you talked about first aid
for a seever jugular look up Scott from
Kentucky ballistics and his injury just
stick a thumb in it yeah that was that
when the yeah blew up and it hit his
neck is that what he did he literally
stuck his thumb in it yeah oh wow and
that and he lived he made it if this
dude who got hit in the neck in the UK
just
went instead he just put his hand on it
and then bled out in 50 seconds y That's
crazy
man the lion says there is no such thing
as Palestine the region was renamed by
the Romans as a slight to the Jews who
had been expelled from the region
following the BK Rebellion philistia
Philistines Palestine right because the
Philistines were people that came from
the water or the water people that came
on the boats yeah I don't know what this
kind of point is this this this poster
is trying to make I think they're trying
to suggest that there's no there's no
historical conflict over the land there
no no no they're arguing that the land
belongs to the Jews yeah that's but
there's a yeah it's kind of like saying
that there isn't a real historical
conflict between the people that live
there and the people that got that that
live there now this was the issue uh uh
one of the issues I had with Max
blumenthall he said I think it was Max
when uh was it Max no it wasn't Max um I
think maybe yeah it was Scott Scott
Horton said this that the people who
currently live in Israel the people who
have always lived there they were Jews
but they were conquered by the Muslims
and told convert or else basically so
they did and then I'm like so the
argument is that a conquered people are
being reconquered like I don't know that
history but but if that's the argument
you're like war is happening again it's
like what I would defend is the property
rights of people that own houses and
things like that they owned property and
they you know they were you know either
scared out of their property or ejected
from it that's for real when I'm sick of
the lies and it's funny because it's
very difficult to get to the bottom of
this history yeah but it's the left
lying like 90% of the time they could
lie but it's just like it's it's it's
just everything we see Donald Trump
didn't overfeed the koish he did what
Shinzo AB did Donald Trump didn't call
Nazis very fine people they just lie
about everything they lie about
everything but sometimes a clock is
right once twice a day a broken clock I
mean sometimes they're right and I don't
discriminate about what's true based on
who's saying it necessarily but guess
what yeah at any point when you look at
a broken clock yeah and you know it's
broken you check another clock yeah
that's true yeah I go for other sources
absolutely I would not go with leftist
propaganda ever so let's amend that they
say a broken clock is right twice a day
find another clock and I would add to
that and yet still you will always check
a working clock
absolutely ver absolutely I would never
rely on leftist uh propaganda for
anything the problem is the average
person just doesn't have the time
inclination or they're not as involved
in this situation to understand that's
and that's it's really is what's
concerned like post concern for me like
everything I read I have no idea without
checking three to four different sources
whether it's true or not and that just
leads a lot of people to disengage I I
go back to Israeli historians actually
and look at what they say these people
that did deep Research into this and uh
that's where I get my source from all
right the Bahamian Rainman says I turned
39 tomorrow and all I want is for y'all
to tell me whether or not Trump's voters
can legitimately write his name in on
the ballot should his name be removed
and whether or not he can still win with
these improvised written bouts no he
can't if his name is removed this then
the state has decided they will not
honor they will not honor those votes As
Trump is ineligible so no matter how
many votes he gets they're not going to
tally them they're going to ignore him
and so a lot of people don't get it if
New York removes Trump's name from the
ballot let's just say New York and uh
how many Republicans they got in New
York five no like 10 million few Upstate
yeah right yeah but that's so let's say
C I think California has 10 million
Republicans and 20 million Democrats so
although it's always going to be
Democrat that's still 10 million votes
to the Republican in the National
popular vote California removes Trump's
name from the ballot and they argue who
cares it's a State anyway that's Terri
then the popular vote comes out and Joe
Biden's got 80 million and Trump's got
65 and then Trump wins The Electoral
College and the left loses it and says
what and then we get four more years of
we need to get rid of the Electoral
College and this will be their excuse
because if Trump wins the elal college
but only gets 37% of the popular vote
they're going to be like two to one
Biden one how are is our country being
ruled by this man without realizing it's
because he took his name off the ballot
yeah that's true and I would say this
even though I hope to be running against
Trump directly I'll say this this is an
outrage uh and what they're doing to him
the legal prosecutions and all this uh
is unbelievable uh it's completely a uh
a miscarriage of Justice entirely and it
should be stopped agreed all right
Daniel kmian says ditching henned for
timcast equals best decision ever that
is correct yes that is a correct
statement I am not a fan of henned I I I
really Tucker awesome awesome no I don't
hand is a is a just a straight down the
line neocon no matter what that's I
remember that one famous handoff where
Tucker was criticizing Amazon for
screwing their employees over and then
you know Hy it does they do the
crossover thing handy defends Amazon and
Tucker's like oh like they they seem to
have been went back then they were like
battling in a for a while there yeah
let's grab some more Donald Dow says I
worked at that secret base near the
southern end of Gaza and the Sinai
desert it's a radar sight appointed at
Iran and has like five US military at it
m and uh ton of
contractors that's crazy well there you
go it's not a secret anymore yep it's
out there hope that wasn't like a
violation of any kind of like
confidentiality well I mean we shouldn't
have the state keeping all these secrets
from us and uh I don't know how many 500
million classified documents that we we
aren't allowed to know about the
emperor's Champion says why do people
act like the CCP Iran and the Russians
are completely innocent and all of this
stuff is 100 10% the fault of the
US well um I will say because the US
won there you go I don't think anybody I
I certainly didn't mean to be saying
that whatsoever well the the issue is
the US wins and then puts a bunch of
bases everywhere and then causes a bunch
of problems we then criticize creating
those problems right yeah yeah Russia's
bad China's bad Iran is very bad they're
all very very bad the bricks nations are
a big threat and I'm I'm really
concerned about South Africa they're
they're they're probably the worst yeah
yeah you can say that I mean one of the
things that people forget about I looked
over at Serge just to said it yeah one
of the things people forget about the US
is that we control we basically keep
International Trade safe with our with
our military our military meaning our
Navy Etc our Naval power I don't know if
the countries would do that they haven't
indicated that they would do that as
well so something people forget about
were uh you were you were born in South
Africa right I was born in Belgium my
parents left South Africa before I was
born there yeah and and why did they
leave South Africa uh well reason South
Africa in the 80s you
I think you could have safe uh
International Trade without a military
per se you could have armed
hypothetically at least a naval people
to stop piracy private protection firms
that would protect property as it moves
through various regions that would
develop over time but that would there
would be with the without that devel
like having the development it it's
going to take time it wouldn't just
agree let get rid of the state I don't
disagree with you I don't disagree with
you I'm not I think a lot of us agree
with you especially on this podcast but
yeah I think uh I think that people
forget how much that uh that protection
it gives so many people so many nations
it literally protects global trade it's
a it's a huge thing another part of that
is like what Trump used to point out
it's like like we get a crap deal out of
this we protect everybody and we get
nothing for it right so that's even a
more neutral take and that's that's the
thing we should be arguing against that
we we have to we have to foot the bill
we have to become the police not just
you know we we're trying to protect
trade that doesn't me to be the World
Police and go get involved in every
conflict and every single war that
happens it's not just us for which makes
us a Target as well we're we're not just
you know salesman for rathon the KL
tanker says I was thinking after you
said yesterday about how conservatives
just need to have kids but as a
California and I have friends that have
heavily conservative parents that try to
pass down their values and their kids
are farle okay this one's really simple
it's because they gave their kids to the
state the school's got them that's it so
it's like you're you're conservative
listen if you're a conservative and you
send your kids to a state-run
institution you're a progressive by
traditional standards the I if go go
back a 100 go back 200 years go to the
founding fathers and have a discussion
with Thomas Jefferson about how your
kids are going to go to a state-run
learning facility and you will not see
them and he's going to be like that's
Insanity that's that's they didn't have
communism they didn't have a word for
pack then but he'll say that's
communism whatever word yeah they put
out little status that's it it's a
status production Factor yeah it's
exactly it's very hard to get away from
that with the economic standards are the
way they are now with both parents
almost all
households are both parents are working
it's very hard to we can do pod learning
stuff like that but it's it's very very
difficult look man all of this is a
choice okay and for these parents who
did not see it coming and thought their
kids would be okay I understand they
were victimized that being said now that
we know these things the answer is make
the difficult decision fig and suffer
the hardships for your children that is
to say get out of the Cities
sell find new jobs and start the process
of look the the the we had colonists who
came from Europe on boats I say this all
the time 20% of them died on the ships
they landed on shore on Barren Shores
and said this is worth it and a lot of
them died you don't even got to do that
all you got to do is go and Craig move
down the move to a different
neighborhood get out of the city start
looking up job listings in in uh Maga
areas in Maga country find a job and
then move and
better than going to to these State
schools unschooling but get get out of
these states and it is not look here
here's here's what I do in skateboarding
what I like to do is I like to imagine a
ridiculously hard trick at as I'm about
to do a somewhat easier version of it so
I try to visualize doing the hardest
version say okay now I pull it back I do
I do a big sale on myself so imagine you
have to bring your you have to run you
have to run through fields of landmines
with your family to escape a
totalitarian regime held bent on locking
up in the gogs and then stop and say oh
thank heavens all I have to do is find a
new job and find and find a house and
sell a bunch of stuff and then move what
do you do about Tik Tok and social media
is it just keeping your kids off the
phone yep yeah it shouldn't be arbitr
you know uh vivet ramaswami actually
said that it should be illegal for
people 18 and under go on the internet
go on social media this is no no I don't
know about that we don't need uh but
like I it's going to be very hard cuz
you said to keep it's got It's what
they're schooling where they're living
and also phones the internet there's all
the ways that this information comes to
them if you if you found out that one of
the moms in your neighborhood was
hosting sex parties for teenagers in the
neighborhood with beer this is an actual
story that just happened would you go
what am I supposed to do tell my kid
they can't hang out with the other kids
like it's is a normal social thing the
kids are doing no you say you cannot go
to that house so when when the the
argument that oh but like Tic Tac is
what all the kids are doing it's like
and if all the kids were jumping off a
bridge would you let your kid do it no
so what do you do move to an area with
similar values keep your kids away from
bad influences because they're absorbing
the world around them and uh yeah don't
let them use these things for as long as
possible for as long as possible and
it's like it's like when your kid turns
18 they get a tattoo and you say look
you're my kid and you live in my house
and my rules when you turn 18 you can go
get a tattoo and smoke cigarettes but
right now you live in my house on no to
and hopefully they won't do it
afterwards by the time they're 18
they'll realize well it really is about
you know these the like the this uh
these conservative parents had far-left
kids because they handed their kids over
to the far-left to the state yeah what I
mean is that they would not become far-
leftist yeah I don't care about tattoo
you need to teach your kids man and you
know you know the the real challenge is
and I don't have kids but I certainly
know this uh just from my upbringing is
it's hard to know if hardship will make
or break you're kid some people are made
by hardship some people are broken by it
but I guess the challenge is you are
worse off not having the hardship if
someone is going to be broken by a
moderate degree of hardship then they
weren't cut out for this and and you got
to figure something out for them yeah
but I think it's better off I really I
really hate the idea of people like I'm
going to I'm going to make sure my kids
never know the hardship I went through
and I'm like why you're successful yeah
then you end up with Elon Musk kid is a
Marxist by the way human being human
beings like we're antifragile like we
need struggle and resistance like
whether it be our biology when like our
bones need gravity or else they become
brittle and they lose Mass the way that
you build your body is by put is putting
resistance on it you have to struggle
with things that you don't understand to
learn things everything about our
existence
requires some kind of struggle and that
is that is that is another thing that is
ubiquitous across all of human society
you don't get anything by just sitting
there you have to go out and there has
so you can't like the the helicopter
parents and the snowplow parents who go
out and just try to make the world flat
for their children are doing their
children a massive disant and our
society is suffering now because again
we're at the point where we have
multiple you know multiple graduating
classes a decade two decades worth of
graduating classes where since No Child
Left Behind since the bush era where
they did stopped failing kids and stop
having you know trying to get kids to
put
Ines get them out just put them through
the system and let them out and that's
why you have a whole a whole slew of
kids that can't read at grade level and
stuff the craziest thing to me this has
been I thought about this my whole life
I I watched uh uh several educational
videos on education I watched uh some
some great TED talks about schooling and
the problems of schooling and uh the
most important years of human beings
life zero through five mhm where the
brain is developing and absorbing
everything around it and what does the
average American do with their kids they
sit them down put them on an iPad and
have him do nothing right before iPads
it was nothing yeah I guess TV TV TV TV
that that's crazy TBS for all of human
history these kids were with their
parents all the time learning from
adults and so we see that viral video
where you've got a bunch of 10-year-olds
talking about the war and it's like
black and white and they sound like
adults and everyone's like why do the
kids sound like this because they were
raised by adults yeah EXA because their
influence was adults they act like
adults they need to be outside by
themselves playing with each other and
you know I mean no no no no no that's
the opposite kids need to be raised by
their parents oh absolutely what I'm
getting at is here they need to have
some Independence they don't need
helicopter parents which are completely
crippling them yeah the issue right now
is that kids are being raised by each
other exactly yeah so we're being raised
by social media or the state mostly the
state yes but
schools at least when I was in school we
had no respect for teachers anything a
teacher said was meaningless garbage and
we made fun of anybody who agreed with a
teacher so the kids had were raising
each other yeah they were get it yep you
have to fit in with the other kids
instead of fitting with the adults sure
I was working for my f my family's
business and so I was surrounded by
adults on the weekends at least and so
I'm like okay that's the behavior
they're engaging it and how do I you
know how do I supposed to behave and
things like this then the kids are all
just doing fart jokes and they grew up
and they do the same thing pretty much
there's a viral photo uh someone had a
tweet and they said 40 years old married
with kids living in the suburbs or this
and it's a mattress on a floor P laundry
yeah and it's like because that person
never grew up because that person was
raised by children and it is I mean it
it it look I I feel for parents who
didn't see this coming and didn't know
you know but at a certain point you have
the responsibility to solve the problems
and to and to and to to to uh see the
pitfalls and the dangers that will
befall your family and if you were like
I got an idea I'm going to give my kids
to the state for 8 hours a day and have
no idea what they're being told or
what's happening what do you get you get
kids being bullied kids killing
themselves you get school shootings you
get Marxism and cultural uh cultural uh
cultural Marxism critical race Theory
because parents were just like genderism
ideology gender ideology because parents
were just
like it it is they abdicated their
responsibility there's a video where a
guy asks dads about their kids and he's
like what's your when's your daughter's
birthday and they don't know what's your
daughter's teacher name no idea yep I'm
like they look I'm sorry if you don't
know the name of your kid's teacher you
don't care yep and and and I'm not
saying that it's a slight that is not
meant to be like I'm insulting you like
how dare you not care no I'm saying like
you literally don't care right yeah like
I don't know the name of the guy who
fixes the septic tank here why well I
don't care what his name is yeah I I
don't I don't handle that someone else
calls and like has that maintained so I
don't care yeah if you don't think about
your teacher your kid's teacher you
don't care maybe you should care that's
all perhaps all right Ian Crossland says
I'm coming for you tomorrow Tim pool oh
no well he's mad because I said if he's
not back by Wednesday we're taking that
Ian Crossland down take it down we're
going to put up a f Phil leonti one we
actually don't have one we got to we got
to hit up the company that made these
because these are really
awesome yeah we got we actually have a
timcast IRL one laying down over there
it's over here oh it's over there yeah
it's over here I got to say this studio
is way bigger than it looks on on air
yeah no yeah yeah the timcast IRL one
yeah yeah I don't know we framed the
timcast one and so we never put the
timcast IRL one up but we probably
should but we should probably get a
bunch of those I just notic the beanie
on that one I just see a lot of
gun this is here's
here's so good yeah Ian has a UFO on it
little little and then uh what did
Luke's have there I don't remember I
think it has his his logo actually and
Lydia's head something has a weirdo yeah
yeah Luke's has his own logo shim cast
but it's fine Sheamus abandoned us so
you know we don't we don't care about
him anymore anyway so you know whatever
Eddie Kaza Kaza says I'm looking for a
gang expert to give expert testimony in
aaso Oklahoma my father unived his
daughter's traffickers who tried to take
her the police are treating traffickers
like the victims just a simple website
site will have the info yeah that's
what's going on it's called anarco
tyranny they're letting criminality run
completely rampant and uh you can't even
defend yourself against criminals it is
not strictly what Libertarians have
always talked about as over policing
what we're seeing here is instead a
terrorizing of people by criminality all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends go to
timcast.net
uh wther regime. comom that's rether
regime. comom and follow me on X or
Twitter at Rec the regime let's do it oh
hey guys uh if you want to follow me you
can follow me on Instagram and Twix
Brett dvic on both of those platforms
and please go ahead and check out pop
culture crisis Monday through Friday 3
pm. Eastern Standard Time that is noon
Pacific you should come hang out with us
I am Phil The Remains on Twix I am Phil
that remains official on Instagram the
band is All That Remains you can follow
us on Spotify Apple music YouTube
Pandora you know the internet and I'm
surge.com enjoying being South African
and the world Champs in rugby having the
web Ellis once more today uh you can
find me on the internet on Twix
surge.com I'm on uh what's it called uh
truth social now which would be sweet I
guess did South Africa win the world cup
or something yeah we beat the All Blacks
we are the winningest country four times
and we're also back to back no big deal
guys like this is like the big game yeah
this is the white Bell this is the Rugby
World Cup oh wow yeah so that's why
that's why I'm so excited so uh yeah bab
bua forever guys all right we'll see you
all over at timcast in a couple minutes
thanks for hanging
out